venu pour cet événement d'importance
donc tout d'abord nous transmettons sur
toutes nos excuses aux voyageurs
malgré en fait tout ce qu'on a pu mettre
en oeuvre pour l'heure leur permettre
d'être réacheminés on comprend le vécu
bien sûr des voyageurs et surtout la
contrariété
alors là je suis en présence de jean lui
gary directeur territorial au niveau de
la nouvelle aquitaine je propose de lui
laisser la main dans un premier temps
pour qu'ils nous fassent en fait le
déroulé des de la multitude d'incidents
et puis après je reprendrai la main pour
tout ce qui est pris en charge aux
voyageurs en deuxième temps
bonjour à tous c'est de revenir on
jean-luc gary comme romain gr y
directeur territorial sncf réseau
nouvelle aquitaine écoutez il s'agit
d'un événement exceptionnel qui a créé
un enchaînement d'incidents et qui
aboutit à un moment donné à
l'interruption des circulations pas
immédiatement pas de suite en dax
d'abord mais au bout d'un certain temps
quelques circulations très peu mais
quelques circulations ont pu reprendre
je vous tourner vers les roms mais
quelques trains ont pu inventer mais on
a eu une succession d'incidents qui nous
a mis dans une situation et a mis les
voyageurs évidemment on pense d'abord
aux voyageurs dans une situation
extrêmement difficile pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé il faut faire un peu de
pédagogie très très peu je vais essayer
d'être très simple on est sur une ligne
électrifiée pour comme train avance sur
une ligne électrifiée
il a besoin au dessus de lui d'un
pornographe sorte de grosse agrafes qui
fait contact avec le fils de ce qu'on
appelle la caténaire l'électricité
circule dans la caténaire c'est à
travers le pantographe qui se baladent
sur la caténaire faire à mesure que le
train avant ce qui conduit l'électricité
dans le train
on a eu ce qu'on sait pas au à cette
heure c'est qui a fait quoi qui a créé
quoi est-ce que c'est un pantographe
défectueux qui a arraché la caténaire
est ce que c'est un élément de la
caténaire défectueux qui pendait parce
que c'est souvent comme ça que ça se
passe
venez les membres de la caténaire à un
moment donné qui a lâché qui pend qui
tape le quant au graff éléments prix
gide du train qu'ils endommagent et
ensuite ce train qui continue son trajet
peu endommagé la caténaire à plusieurs
endroits voilà donc il ya une enquête
qui est en cours interne évidemment pour
savoir exactement ce qui s'est passé
parce que c'est quand même important
pour éviter que ça se reproduise
même si on sait qu'en l'occurrence c'est
très difficile mais c'est pas la
première fois mais c'est une situation
exceptionnelle ce qu'il faut comprendre
si jamais ça j'ai à faire passer c'est
la succession d'événements qu'on a
connus depuis le samedi 20 heures le
samedi 29 à 20 heures et quelques on a
eu ensuite un problème en gare de dax et
puis on a ensuite des problèmes sur
morcenx et puis sur puyoo et puis sur i
shook ce soir voilà il ya une carte
créée par là on va essayer de vous
mettre une carte je pense qu'il faut
bien comprendre que sur quasiment
l'ensemble du sud aquitaine on a eu des
événements de la même nature qui se sont
reproduits et qui sont sans doute dues à
la même cause elle sait pas c'est pas
une lecture x et de l'ensemble du
système
c'est une cause qui s'est reproduite et
qui a créé plusieurs incidents dans la
journée
c'est pas forcément un défaut de
maintenance je peux pas vous le dire à
l'heure actuelle on va procéder je vous
ai dit situation exceptionnelle mesures
exceptionnelles
on va procéder à la vérification de tous
les trains qui ont circulé sur ces
sections là si je fais simple qu'encore
une fois vous voyez bien que entre
bordeaux et dax à dax on a quelque chose
comme une patte d'oie
on a un axe qui va vers bayonne et
ensuite en un axe qui va vers pau orthez
pau tarbes et donc les trains il ya des
trains qui vont circuler entre orthez et
bayonne il ya des trains qui ont circulé
entre pau orthez tuyaux dax bordeaux
c'est comme ça qu'on retrouve les
problèmes sur l'ensemble sur l'ensemble
du réseau
il se trouve que on a identifié un
élément de caténaire à orthez défectueux
on sait pas encore si c'est ça encore
une fois est-ce que c'est un train qui a
fait en dommages et la caténaire ou
est-ce que l'élément a lâché andy 20 g
en train qui ensuite en circulant de
toute façon le résultat c'est qu'un
train à circuler endommagé et il a par
la suite sur l'ensemble du réseau enfin
sur l'ensemble de son tracé endommagé la
caténaire à plusieurs endroits et
pourquoi
à morcenx à puyoô et à dax parce que ça
se fait sur les aiguillages c'est au
moment où vous avez un aiguillage et
donc les filles se croisent dans tous
les sens q comme tantôt graff défectueux
accroche encore ni comment ni les fils
de la caténaire donc défaut de
maintenance je sais pas j'en sais rien
mais c'est un train qui a tout connu
l' enquête est en cours a priori ça
pourrait être ça mais l'enquêté est en
cours et on vous le dira lorsqu'on aura
les résultats
d'abord on travaille à restituer du mois
on travaille à rétablir et à remettre en
service tout le système
c'est la priorité c'est la priorité la
priorité c'est de faire circuler les
trains le plus vite possible pour ça il
faut faire ce que j'ai dit les
vérifications
elle commence cet après midi elles se
dérouleront le temps qu'il faut pour
être sûr que lorsqu'on remet en route on
n'a pas de nouveau de problèmes
notre priorité a été la prise en charge
de nos voyageurs pour vraiment raconter
ce qui s'est passé en fait on a eu un
incident sur un train le 85 38 en
garderie shox à l'incident pantographes
et donc on a dû déclencher un
transbordement
donc on a
fait venir une rame de bordeaux avec la
protection civile à bord avec de
l'avitaillement donc offrir au pae
également
bouteilles d'eau et on est arrivé on est
arrivé à proximité du train en pleine
voie et on a organisé un transbordement
en plein de voix est en pleine nuit dans
notre préoccupation quand je voulais dit
c'était l'avitaillement des voyageurs et
puis après tout notre préoccupation
c'est de réaliser le transbordement en
toute sécurité
ce que nous avons fait il y avait des
personnes en situation de handicap
on a pu les les traiter les faire
basculer sur le train qu'on a pu ré
acheminement après en gare de bordeaux
et qui est parti bien sûr avant de le
faire partir il y avait aussi tout ce
qui était petit déjeuner est également
des boissons et on a mis aussi dans le
train des ressources pour voyager avec
eux et pour les acheminer en gare de
paris
donc ça c'était le premier train après
les comme ce train était bloqué en gare
du chox on a fait revenir
deux tgv en fait sur en garde
hendaye et six tgv en gare de hendaye on
a eu 400 445 personnes qui sont restées
en garde et hendaye et à l'heure
actuelle on a mobilisé des bus pour les
les prendre en charge
et bien sûr pour les acheminer à
bordeaux pour après les acheminer à
paris ces personnes à hendaye ont été
aussi avitailler en termes de coffrets
repas et puis de bouteilles d'eau
alors à chaque passage en fait des
trains on a on a déployé des ressources
sur en tout pour gérer la succession des
incidents on a déployé plus de 200
ressources s'asseoir au sol ou pour
l'accompagnement ou tout ce qu'ils
étaient et services techniques et donc à
chaque passage ont proposé de l'eau mais
tout le monde comprend que quand on a un
train bloqué en pleine voie comme les 85
38 est con on devait faire
l'avitaillement à bordeaux et comme
l'incident s'est passé en garde e-shops
on a pris les décisions avec la
protection civile de en fait d'embarquer
tous les concerts au pas les bouteilles
d'eau et d amener au transbordement
voilà donc notre préoccupation ça a été
celle ci en toute sécurité
et puis maintenant que notre occupation
c'est pouvoir finaliser ou finir
l'acheminement des voyageurs d'hendaye
surtout en garde paris comme on a fait
pour le tgv qui était arrêté et quand la
trans border itunes les acheminer
également à paris alors en termes de en
termes de remboursement
on dit 300% qu'est ce que ça veut dire
300% déjà on va rembourser le billet et
en fait on va avoir deux billets de plus
gratuit donc ça c'est dans un premier
temps est également on va on va voir une
prise en charge totale des frais annexes
par rapport à votre question tout ce qui
fait un ex si il ya des frais annexes
d'hôtel des des couches et des trucs
comme ça donc sous présentation de
factures liées à l'incident mais on sera
bien sûr très attentif à rembourser ses
frais annexes
[Musique]
alors il aurait tant bisman on travaille
de concert bien sûr avec réseau pour en
fait qu'ils remettent en tant qu ils
remettent en situation nominal le réseau
donc il faut faire des reconnaissances
des reconnaissances sur les voies au
niveau des caténaires et dont on estime
que l'heure et demie le rétablissement
normal du réseau se fera demain
peut-être une précision jérôme il ya
environ plus de 100 personnes près de
200 personnes qui travaillent depuis
hier entre réseaux mobilité enfin
voyageurs est ce que ce mois qui sont
mobilisés dirais qu'on a même des
renforts de midi pyrénées qui sont venus
pour travailler sur le secteur puisque
comme vous l'avez compris la zone est
vaste on va d'orthez bayonne jusqu'à x1
voir ambarès
donc c'est très vaste il ya eu un effet
boule de neige
c'est un effet boule de neige vous savez
c'est comme c'est comme le flottement
d'aile d'un papillon vous connaissez
l'histoire
1 voilà à orthez un élément de
caténaires voilà qui pend qui est
accroché par un train si la cause est là
se reproduit et fait sentir son effet un
peu partout sur le réseau
là où le train n'a circulé
on sait pas on est en train d'expertiser
tous les trains pardon excusez moi on
est en train d'expertiser tous les
trains qui sont passés sur ces sections
vous voyez que ça représente un paquet
de train un et on verra les trains qui
ont été touchés comment ils ont été
touchés
on arrivera à savoir qu'est ce qui a
déclenché si c'est la caténaire qui a
déclenché un incident si c'est le train
qui a déclenché un incident sur la
caténaire qui a déclenché ensuite
l'incident sur le train et je vais
repasser la parole à jérôme et moi ce
que je peux dire c'est que on a fait
tout ce qu'on pouvait on a fait tout ce
qu'on pouvait il ya énormément de moyens
qui ont été mobilisés on peut toujours
s'améliorer mais beaucoup de choses ont
été faites
pas moi